four billion years ago asteroids rained
down on the newly formed moon tearing
into the surface where the fractured
crust is thinnest molten lava seeps from
the moon's hot interior spreads out and
giant pools and solidifies to form the
scars we see today from Earth
and strangely
although the moon rotates the Earth's
gravity holds on to it so tightly the
same face points towards us at all times
making the features on the far side of
the moon a complete mystery for all of
history the far side of the Moon was
invisible to the earth it's the back
side you can't see it
in 1959 Soviet spacecraft Luna 3 flies
past the moon's far side and photographs
it for the first time astronomers expect
to see the familiar dark and light
patches they were in for a big surprise
when scientists saw the pictures they
were shocked the far side looked
completely different than the near side
it's saturated with craters it just was
such a huge dichotomy nobody was
expecting that at all
the far side still had massive impact
craters
but it was uniformly pale it seemed like
no dark lava had bled out onto the
surface at all but why the only solution
we could come up with is there's a
difference in thickness between the
crust of the nearside and the crust of
the farside the backside must be so
thick that lavas are not able to come up
through them and erupt out onto the
surface instead on the front side where
it's very thin lavas can easily come up
through cracks and flow out onto the
surface recent NASA missions confirm the
crust on the back of the Moon is around
30 miles thicker than the crust on the
front the far side is thicker it's not
like Oh
part of it is and part of it isn't no
it's really the other side of the Moon
has a thicker crust than the near side
that's bizarre so one of the biggest
mysteries in planetary science over the
last about 50 years is you know why is
the crust to the far side so thick the
impact Theory doesn't really cover that
it just forms the moon but it doesn't
say why one side should be so different
than the other one unless something
strange happened
the New Age of supercomputers brings
about the first credible explanation the
impact of theá-- could have made two
moves not one
at this double birth white also
explained our double-sided Lu
according to the theory 4.5 billion
years ago there are two moons in the
night sky the smaller moon chases its
larger sibling gradually getting closer
eventually the two moons mushed together
in slow motion and the smaller moon
covers the far side of the larger moon
creating a new much thicker crust not
all impacts are high speed super violent
events that eject material everywhere
instead of just wham smacking into it it
would have just merged with it just been
pulled apart and smeared out over the
moon essentially when you look at one
half of the moon you see more of one
body and we look at the other side of
the Moon you see more of the other body
they kind of wrapped around the first
body and so it's thicker on that side